THAT'S JUST IN A MOMENT.
FIRST TONIGHT THERE IS
ALWAYS SOMETHING A LITTLE
POIGNANT ABOUT THE END OF
SOMETHING.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY PEOPLE GET
DRUNK ON NEW YEAR'S EVE TO
FORGET IT.
SAD TO THINK THAT A WHOLE
YEAR IS OVER.
IF YOU THINK NEW YEAR'S IS
DEPRESSING.
HOW FAR WOULD YOU FEEL IF
YOU THOUGHT THAT ALL LIFE ON
THIS PLANET WAS ENDING SOON?
3 MILLION YEARS OF HUMAN
HISTORY ERASED FOREVER.
SAD.
ISN'T IT?
CHRIS HASTE
CHRIS HAYTE
CHRIS HAYES THINK SO CHRIS
HAYES IS WHAT EVERY MAN
WOULD BE APOLOGETIC, A SPECK
SPECTACLE AND DEEPLY DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT GLOBAL
WARMING AND THE PATRIARCH
CALL.
HE HOSTED A TOWN HALL EVENT
WITH ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ DESIGNED TO
PROMOTE HER GREEN NEW DEAL.
THIS APPARENTLY SEEMED LIKE
A WISE IDEA TO EXECUTIVES AT
MSNBC.
THE VERY SAME NEWS OUTLETS
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING
TO BUT RUSSIA BRINGS YOU A
29-YEAR-OLD FORMER BARTENDER
TO TEACH YOU ABOUT SCIENCE.
HAYES FRAMED THE TERMS AT
THE OUTSOUTHWEST SHOW UNLESS
YOU DO EXACTLY WHAT
DR. OCASIO-CORTEZ SAYS, THE
ENTIRE HUMAN RACE HAS ONLY
12 YEARS TO LIVE.
>> WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
AVOID THE MOST CATASTROPHIC
EFFECTS OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IS TO CUT EMISSIONS
IN HALF IN 12 YEARS.
12 YEARS.
THAT'S THE PROJECT WE HAVE
BEEN TASKED WITH BY THE
EARTH.
HAS COME A BOLD NEW POLICY
PROPOSAL THAT MIGHT BE THE
MOST CONTROVERSIAL THING IN
AMERICAN POLITICS AT THE
MOMENT.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT IT
IT'S CALLED THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT A
SOCIALIST MONSTER.
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT OUR ONLY
HOPE FOR SURVIVAL HERE IN
THE WAY OF LIFE THAT WE HOLD
DEAR.
>> Tucker: LOOKS LIKE ELLEN
KIND OF A FUSION SHOW.
DID YOU HEAR WHAT HE SAID?
OUR ONLY HOPE FOR SURVIVAL.
HOLY SMOKES.
THAT IS TERRIFYING.
HELP US CHRIS HAYES.
WHAT IS THIS LIFE RAFT THIS
HUMANITY SAVING ANTIDOTE
THAT ALONE CAN PREVENT THE
DEATH OF OUR CHILDREN?
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS
THE CURE FOR HUMAN
EXEXTINCTION.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS OBEY
HER AND BE VERY, VERY GOOD
PEOPLE.
>> IN MY FRAMEWORK, IN MY
BELIEFS THAT WE NOT JUST
HAVE A WEALTHY SOCIETY, BUT
THAT WE HAVE A MORAL
SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND,
YOU MAY BE WONDERING.
HOW DOES A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WHO HASN'T YET
TURNED 30, SOMEONE WHO HAS
NEVER EVEN RAISED CHILDREN,
GET THE RIGHT TO LECTURE ME
ABOUT MORALITY?
WELL, THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOU AND ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, SHE IS A
HIGHLY DECENT PERSON.
LISTEN TO HER EXPLAIN HOW
SHE DOESN'T RESORT TO AD
HOMINEM ATTACKS UNLIKE HER
ENEMIES WHO BY THE WAY ARE
XENOPHOBIA WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
>> ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVE.
WE ARE NOT CALLING ANYONE
NAMES.
PEOPLE SAY TEA PARTY OF THE
LEFT.
I FIND THIS PHRASE VERY
INTERESTING.
THIS PHRASING VERY
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
GROUNDING OF THE TEA PARTY
WAS XENOPHOBIA, THE UNDER
PINNINGS OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> YEAH, STOP WITH THE
NAME-CALLING YOU RACIST
WHITE SUPREMACIST
XENOPHOBIA.
SO, IT'S OFFICIAL ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ IS A MORON AND
NASTY AND MORE
SELF-RIGHTEOUS THAN ANY
TELEVANGELIST WHO EVER
PREACHED A SERMON ON CABLE
ACCESS.
SHE IS NOT OPPRESS YOU HAD
SHE IS NOT IPPRESS YOU HAD
SHE IS NOT IMPRESS YOU HAD
SHE IS NOT IMPRESSEDOU HAD
SHE IS NOT IMPRESSED.U HAD
HOW DO PEOPLE LIKE HER?
NOT EVERYTHING SHE SAYS IS
WRONG.
LISTEN TO THIS CLIP FROM THE
SAME TOWN HALL.
OCASIO-CORTEZ TAKE AS BREAK
FROM HER IDIOTIC CLIMATE TO
OFFER CRITIQUE OF THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
>> WE HAVE RUN AWAY INCOME
INEQUALITY.
WE ARE AT ONE OF OUR MOST
INEQUAL POINTS ECONOMICALLY
SPEAKING IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
WE ARE DEALING WITH A CRISIS
OF HOW OUR ECONOMY IS EVEN
MADE UP.
OUR ECONOMY IS INCREASINGLY
FINANCIALIZED WHICH MEANS WE
ARE MAKING PROFITS OFF OF
INTEREST, OFF LEASING YOUR
PHONE, OFF OF DOING ALL OF
THESE THINGS, BUT WE AREN'T
PRODUCING AND WE AREN'T
INNOVATING IN THE WAY THAT
WE NEED TO AS AN ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
YOU HATE TO ADMIT IT, GIVEN
THE SOURCE, BUT TRY TO
IGNORE THE WAY SHE SAID IT
MAYBE JUST PRINT IT OUT AND
READ IT A LOT OF IT IS
BASICALLY TRUE.
NO OTHER
PARTY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
REPUBLICANS ARE IN FETAL
POSITION THEY WILL DO
ANYTHING NOT TO BE
UNPOPULAR.
DEMOCRATS WANT TOTAL AND
COMPLETE CONTROL OVER YOU
AND THIS COUNTRY.
NEITHER PARTY WILL SAY THAT
OUR ECONOMY AT ITS CORE IS
BADLY DISTORTED.
ANY ECONOMY, BASED ON
INTEREST PAYMENTS ISN'T
REALLY AN ECONOMY, IT'S A
SCAM.
HEALTHY COUNTRIES INNOVATE.
THEY MAKE THINGS.
THINK DON'T TREAT PEOPLE
LIKE INTERCHANGEABLE
WIDGETS.
THEY DON'T WORSHIP FINANCE.
IN A HEALTHY COUNTRY,
BANKERS AREN'T HEROES.
PRIVATE EQUITY IS NOT THE
HIGHEST PAID PROFESSION.
NOBODY BRAGS ABOUT WORKING
AT A HEDGE FUND.
IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW, WE
HAVE THE OPPOSITE,
UNFORTUNATELY.
THAT'S WHY ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS A
CONSTITUENCY NOT BECAUSE SHE
IS IMPRESSIVE.
SHE'S NOT.
BUT BECAUSE SHE IS ONE OF
THE VERY FEW PEOPLE WHO WILL
SAY THE OBVIOUS ABOUT
GROWING CORPORATE TYRANNY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IT DOESN'T MEAN SHE IS RIGHT
ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE.
TAKING POWER FROM THE BANKS
AND GIVING IT TO
OCASIO-CORTEZ AS SHE
PROPOSES WOULD NOT SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS.